one of the great statesmen of our age is
not
a republican politician he's not a
democrat politician he's not a dictator
he's not an oligarch
he is tom brady tom brady was at the
white house this week
and he demonstrated such political skill
at some point this guy's gonna have to
run for office he's so
obviously very good looking very popular
very wealthy
he checks every box for a politician
but he also strikes the right note
so tom brady standing right next to
president biden
made some pretty wild political jokes
and no one can quite tell where where
they landed
but we found our rhythm we got on a roll
not a lot of people
uh you know think that we could have won
and um in fact i think about 40 percent
of people still don't think we won
i understand you understand that mr
president i understand that yeah
and personally you know it's nice for me
to be back here
we had a game in chicago where i forgot
what down it was
i lost track of one down and 21 years of
playing
and they started calling me sleepy tom
sleepy tom okay now obviously someone
either at the white house
or on tom brady's team wrote the jokes
maybe both
but the jokes are really good political
jokes
and they're really good political jokes
especially for this moment where tom
brady
who is very famously friends with donald
trump
is he's not boycotting the white house
like all those immature athletes who
didn't like trump
but he's showing up there and he's
making some jokes about biden
but the jokes could be seen to biden's
benefit so the first one is yeah people
didn't think we could win about 40
of people still don't think we could win
yeah you know what that's like mr
president
because biden can go along with the joke
because
brady did win so he's saying yeah those
40 people are wrong
but also he's getting the making the
point from the white house that 40
of americans don't believe joe biden won
that election that's a pretty
pretty indicting number then
you see him make the sleepy tom joke
yeah you know i forgot this
and they called me sleepy tom well
he's the part of the joke that biden can
go along with is that
you know look this just happened once
and people are making a big deal about
this
but the part of the joke that's actually
pro-trump and anti-biden
is he's saying yeah i made i i forgot
something and so people are comparing me
to you
mr president who you can't remember
anything because you're a daughtering
old man it's just
ver i'm not i'm not saying like yeah tom
you totally roasted biden and i'm not
saying tom you jerk you sold out trump
i just want to point out the political
skill of
of staying right on that line walking
that tightrope
very very impressive stuff for uh if
and when tom brady wants to get involved
in politics
it was rather charming too it's kind of
a gentleman you know i mean when you
think of
all these athletes today who are just
making these childish ugly
statements colin kaepernick the hammer
girl from the olympics you just think
ugh
gross tom brady shows up there and he
just has a little bit of charm and he
tells some jokes and he jokes
you can laugh at them if you're on the
right you can laugh at them if you're on
the left
i think we need more of that in politics
i'm so
pleased that you liked that clip i am
i'm very happy now i want to help you
by letting you know that there's a full
episode that you can watch it's called
slipping the surly bonds of earth you
can get it here on youtube
ring the bell subscribe comment you can
get it on apple podcast google play
stitcher spotify myspace
aol instant messenger hotmail i don't
know you can get it anywhere and you can
also get my book the number one national
bestselling speechless
controlling words controlling minds see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you